CHELSEA DERRICK: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to True Grit, Debugging
CSS and Render
Performance.
My name is Chelsea Derrick and
I'm a Software Engineer at
Google on the Gmail Team.
I'm going to kick
us off with an
incredibly provocative statement.
Fast is better than flow.
This is actually a part of
Google's 10 Things, which is
our corporate philosophy.
And it's Number Three on that
list, and we put it there
explicitly because we don't
get speed for free.
We have to spend a lot of blood,
sweat, and tears to get
our apps to go quickly.
And when we're talking about
web applications in
particular, there's just a
lot of room to optimize.
We start out trying to minimize
the number of
redirects, get the user to the
landing page immediately, make
sure that when they log in,
it's a quick and easy
experience.
Then--
this is near and dear to my
heart on the Gmail team--
any sort of data look we have
to do on the back end, get
emails, get docs, get posts,
anything like that.
Network delay.
I've often suggested that Google
take some of that money
out of the bank and just move
all of our users a little
closer to the data center.
Not generally something that we
can do, however, we can try
to reduce the number of bytes
we send across the wire.
That'll speed up our
page a little bit.
And then as we're getting
closer and closer to the
client, we start worrying about
things like JavaScript
execution, and finally,
rendering.
This is what we're here
to talk about today.
And in particular, especially
given that I work on a product
where sometimes, it takes five,
ten seconds for an email
to load, it can be very tempting
to spend all of our
time worrying about
back end latency.
However, that just isn't
quite good enough.
So even though we're
talking about much
smaller periods of time--
often milliseconds when we're
talking about rendering--
we can't look at that as just
a drop in the bucket.
That time is really, really
important to our users.
So in particular, I've got a
quick little demo here for you
guys to show exactly
how important it is
to have fast rendering.
So I've got the slow version
of this turned on.
Unfortunately, apps don't
come with these links.
But you can see that
my scrolling here
is incredibly choppy.
I put an empty for loop in here
to demonstrate my point,
but there are few things on
this earth that are more
irritating than choppy
scrolling, right?
If we were to compare that, for
example, to a nice, smooth
scrolling, the user's going to
get a much better experience.
So again, we're only talking
about a delay of a few
milliseconds sometimes, but
it really does have a very
profound impact on our
user's experiences.
So part of that is going to be
freeing up the UI thread.
Browser UIs you run in a single
thread, so we have to
share that between rendering
and JavaScript.
But just making sure we've got
really efficient, performant
JavaScript is not enough.
So I'm going to take us a level
past that, assume that
we've already made that
optimization.
What can we do to make
our pages quick?
So traditionally, the way that
I've done this in the past, I
will start commenting out
sections of JavaScript and see
which one I add back
in makes it faster.
This is irritating, even more
irritating when you have to do
this with your CSS.
Is it the box shadow that's
slowing me down?
Is it the rounded corners?
This is not the best way
to approach things.
It can get pretty irritating.
Fortunately, there are a number
of tools available,
particularly in Chrome today.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about some Chrome Dev
Tools today.
In particular, there are various
profilers available
for JavaScript and for CSS.
And the one that I'm really
going to focus on today is the
Chrome Timeline.
This is a quick little
screenshot, and we can
basically tell the browser to
start recording what we do,
and it will give us information
about where its
time is being spent.
And in particular, we're going
to worry about the things that
are associated with
rendering today.
So there are going to be a few
different annotations we'll
see in the Timeline that
indicate a problem with our
rendering pipeline.
The first one will be
Style Recalculation.
We'll talk a bit about what each
of these mean shortly.
Layout, I'm sure we're all
familiar with that one.
Avoid Layouts.
And lastly, Painting.
So I do want to show really
quickly what this would look
like, and I'll zoom in a bit so
that hopefully those of you
in the back can see.
Here we've got the Chrome
Timeline, and I'm just going
to go ahead and record
what happens when
I click this button.
It's going to add a little bit
of margin on there, so we'll
see all of these things occur.
So I'm going to go ahead and hit
Record, and then I'll head
up here, click on the button,
and then stop recording.
So Chrome has given us
a few little frames
that we can look at.
Let's see here.
And in particular, we see
all of these steps.
We see a style recalculation
occurring.
And if I zoom back a little bit
further, we'll see a layout--
apologies--
a layout right here.
We notice that the whole
screen turns blue.
This is the browser telling us
Layouts are the worst thing
that has ever happened.
And then there's a series of
paints, and actually if I
hover over those, Chrome is
going to show me exactly how
big of a rectangle
got painted.
These are just the hovers on
the button, but when I
actually added the margin, it
affected everything below it
on the page as well because
margin is part of the box
model, so it pushed
other things down.
So that's just a quick look at
the tool itself, which is
really helpful, but even more
useful is knowing exactly what
causes periods of time
to be spent in
those different phases.
So what I'd like to spend the
majority of this talk doing is
explaining a little bit about
the rendering cycle.
So we have information about
the Timeline, but we don't
really have any information
about what caused particular
chunks of time to go missing.
And so by understanding a
little bit about how the
rendering cycle is implemented
in browsers, we can have a
more clear understanding of
maybe what caused a layout or
what caused a paint to occur.
So first of all, any edit that
we make to the document is
going to cause the rendering
cycle to be entered, and here
are the steps that we're going
to be working with--
updating the DOM itself,
calculating CSS property
values, building the rendering
tree, and then using that to
perform layout calculations.
And then there are two more
steps at the end, which are
paint and compositing.
So let's look at each one of
these in a bit more detail.
So first of all, the DOM is
basically an API that provides
access to HTML documents.
The browser parses this and
provides us with a tree of
objects that we can manipulate
with JavaScript.
Now, this is the first
step for a reason.
Everything else in the whole
rendering cycle depends on
this being accurate.
So when we, for example, add a
child or change a class name,
the first thing that has to
happen is we have to actually
edit the DOM.
This may be familiar to you if
you have used the Dev Tools
Element Inspector.
We'll see a tree representation
of our
document, and that's actually
going to be
reflecting the DOM itself.
And here's a little snippet of
JavaScript with some examples
of things we might do to
cause the browser to
have to edit the DOM.
We might set the inner text or
inner HTML, we might add or
remove children, or we might
even just change the
attributes on an element.
Any of these things are going to
cause the browser to enter
the rendering cycle and
go to step number one.
The next thing that the browser
does, once it's got an
accurate snap of the DOM, is
it's going to calculate CSS
property values.
So that means for every single
element on the page, the
browser has to have a value for
every single CSS property.
Depending on what kind of
element you're looking at,
this is often upwards of 200
different properties.
So we can kind of get a glimpse
of all the work that
the browser is doing.
In the Chrome Inspector, if we
take a look at this Computed
Style Zippy, we can see that
there are just a ton of
properties here.
Fortunately, browsers today are
fast, but it's still an
amount of work that has to be
done before we can actually
make updates.
So here's an example of just a
menu toggle button that we
might have in our HTML and
then some CSS that
goes along with it.
We've got Hover Selector.
We might behave a little bit
differently when the menu is
open versus closed.
Same thing if we've disabled
the Menu button.
And going on a little bit
further, we see some
JavaScript that's going to cause
style recalculations.
So if we set that Disabled
Attribute to be true, the
browser is actually going to
have to start recalculating
styles again because
we can put HTML
attributes in our CSS selectors.
And here, I've highlighted the
key things that will cause
style recalculation.
Things like pseudo classes, such
as Hover or Active, can
actually also cause a
style recalculation.
The browser had to go, through
find new matches for all of
our properties, and potentially
change the value
for various CSS properties.
Once we've got all of our CSS in
place, we're going to start
getting into the
layout portion.
And the first step of that
is building a new tree.
We already have the DOM,
however, the rendering tree is
sort of an internal data
structure that the browser
uses to perform layout tasks.
It might be shaped differently
than the DOM and it might
contain different things.
So here are some examples.
In the DOM, we're always going
to have elements and nodes.
These are the entries that we
see in the DOM, and that's
contrasted with the rendering
tree where we see boxes.
Those are things that are
actually painted on the page.
And in terms of the shape of
the rendering tree, we
actually have a different
parenting strategy.
It's not necessarily the case
that a DOM parent is going to
be the parent in the
rendering tree.
So first, let's talk
a little bit about
elements versus boxes.
They're related, but they're
not the same.
So a box is going to be any
entity that gets rendered on
the page, whereas an element is
just going to be an entry
in the DOM.
So here's some examples of
elements that might never be
rendered on the page.
Things that are displayed
None will not be in
the rendering tree.
Style tags, script tags,
the head tag--
any of those things are elements
but not boxes.
Similarly, there are lots of
generated boxes that we do not
have access to in the DOM.
Examples include any pseudo
elements that we've added to
our CSS, line boxes.
If we've got a large paragraph
of text with many lines, the
browser is laying those
out in boxes.
And any other generate a box,
like an anonymous box.
These are all going to
be painted but not
present in the DOM.
And then there's a good deal
of overlap in the middle--
Divs, Anchors, things
that are painted
that are also elements.
So in addition to the fact that
we might have different
content inside of these
trees, they can also
have a different shape.
So a parent in the DOM tree is
always going to be the parent
in the HTML.
However, the parent in the
rendering tree is always going
to be a boxes containing
block.
And if you ever decide that
you just need some fun on
Friday night and you read the
CSS spec, you'll see lots of
references to the containing
block when you are reading the
layout module.
And in general, we actually do
see a lot of correlation
between the DOM tree and the
rendering tree, but there are
some notable exceptions.
Absolutely positioned boxes
are the most obvious one.
So whenever we're looking for a
rendering tree parent for an
absolute box, the browser's
actually walking up the DOM
looking for a positioned
ancestor.
So this is going to be some
other parent in the tree--
or an ancestor, rather--
that has a position property
other than static.
This will be the parent
in the rendering tree.
So I've got a bit of an example
on the next page.
So there's a bit of HTML here,
and I'm going to show you the
differences between the DOM tree
and the rendering tree.
So as we're parsing along with
our HTML, we notice we've got
this section element.
It has a Div child.
That Div child itself
has got a text node.
It's got this Nav element,
which has a text
node itself, et cetera.
We can keep on parsing
all the way down.
This is the structure
we expect.
We put in valid HTML, we
got a tree back that
looked exactly the same.
Now if we were to go back and
build the rendering tree from
the same piece of HTML,
it's going to look
a little bit different.
So our root element
is the same.
It's just going to
be a block box.
And we are definitely going
to have that Div as its
descendant.
However, something a little bit
different starts to happen
when we reach that absolutely
positioned Nav element.
This is actually going to become
a sibling of that Div
because this section is
positioned relative, so that
Nav is going to be parented
under that section element.
We also notice that we start
getting some anonymous boxes
that the browser generates
for us.
This is because any given box
in the tree wants to have
homogeneous children.
So soon as a particular box has
a block child, it wants
all block children.
As soon as it has an
inline child, it
wants all inline children.
So the browser is going to do
whatever it has to to meet
that constraint.
And when we finish, there's a
tree that is certainly shaped
differently but is in a really
good position to perform
layout tasks.
So this is all setting us up to
do a layout pass later on.
We've already decided what
everyone's containing block
is, so we know its containing
width, all
those kinds of things.
Let's talk a little bit about
the properties that are going
to affect the rendering tree.
The first one is going to
be the display property.
Is this a block or
an inline box?
Is it Display None, in which
case it's not even in the
rendering tree at all?
Is it a float?
Is it position fixed, position
absolute, position relative,
or position static?
Any edits that we make to these
properties are going to
cause the browser to have to
make some kind of change to
the rendering tree.
There also some affects on
layers, which we'll talk about
a bit later on.
But in general, the rendering
tree, again, has set us up to
do a layout pass.
And when we talk about layout,
all we really mean is that we
have to determine the position
and dimensions of every box.
How tall is it, how wide is it,
and where is its top left
corner, in most cases.
So the kinds of properties we're
talking about here is
going to be anything to do
with the box model, so
content, padding, border,
margin, and any coordinates.
So if we've got an absolutely
positioned box, for example,
the top, right, bottom,
and left properties.
So you'll notice that there is
sometimes a different set of
properties for these
two different parts
of the layout phase.
Now at this point, the browser
has determined where
everything needs to go but
hasn't actually shown these
changes to the user.
So the next thing that
to happen is paint.
And a few things happen opaquely
to us as developers,
but in the end, the browser
has a couple of tasks.
One, it has to determine, what
color does every pixel on the
page need to be painted?
It needs to actually create
a bitmap that has that
information, and then it needs
to send that to the GPU so
that it can actually be
presented to the user.
Now, a given pixel can only
have one particular color.
So as you might expect, we can
incur some extra costs here if
we have any transparency.
We can't stop at
the top layer.
We have to keep looking
underneath it to calculate
exactly what color to
paint this pixel.
You can get especially slow if
we're talking about anything
that has text because text is
anti-aliased and there are
lots of little transparent
pixels around every letter.
So one other thing to note
is the browser doesn't
necessarily have
one big bitmap.
When we were looking at the
timeline earlier on, you saw
small rectangles that were being
updated rather than the
whole thing at once.
And so there are a number of
strategies the browser uses to
pick small damaged rectangles,
and one of those is it can
have several different layers.
So we can actually tell
the browser how to
slice the page up.
I know that all these things
are likely to stay together
relative to each other, so keep
all these in one layer.
And then it would be the GPU's
job to put all of those
together in the next step.
I do want to point out that
although browser vendors tend
to be going towards this layer
strategy, it's not specified
behavior anywhere.
So it is an implementation
detail, one that we certainly
want to take advantage of when
we're trying to get a really
fast experience, but also one
that we can't say will still
be there in a couple of years.
Hopefully, we won't have to
worry about it anymore.
So we've got a bunch of bitmaps
that's been handed
over to us, and we need to
composite them together.
So all these layer bitmaps are
handed over to the GPU.
The GPU sticks them all together
and then draws those
things on the screen.
Now, anywhere we see some sort
of hand-off from the CPU to
the GPU to the actual render,
those are all going to incur
some sort of cost because we're
transferring this object
around in memory, so that's
something to keep in mind.
But something else to note is
that the GPU, it turns out, is
very fast at drawing things.
This make sense.
The first G is for graphics.
So it's much better for us
to spend as much time in
compositing rather
than painting
if we have the choice.
So properties that the
compositor is really good at
are going to be opacity.
If we're just doing some sort
of transition or something
that just changes opacity, the
GPU can do this all on its
own, and same thing
with transforms.
So that's going to be anything
like a rotation, a skew, a
translation, any of those things
that move a particular
element around the screen.
Transform is very--
well, I think it's
very interesting.
You may or may not.
We can move things around the
page without actually
affecting layout.
So typically, when we move
things around the page, we're
using the position relative
and we change the left
property, or we'll add some
margin, something like that,
but all those are taking us
back to the layout step.
However, if we're relying just
on transformation to do that,
this element is totally
out of the flow.
The layout engine, the rendering
tree still thinks
it's in the original location,
so it's not dirtying up
anything else anywhere
on the page.
Now, this also has the side
effect that it's not pushing
anything out of its way, so
maybe you have to move other
things as well.
But to get certain kinds of
effects, this can be a very
handy thing to know.
So if we look back over the
rendering cycle that we've
just discussed, we can see
that there is definitely
alignment with the things
the Timeline tells us.
So in terms of updating the
DOM and doing our style
recalc, those are all going
to fall under the Style
Recalculation that we saw.
And then we've got all
of this layout work.
We have to make any updates to
the rendering tree, and then
actually calculate the layout.
And then at the very end, we've
got a painting step and
then compositing layers, which
I did not show you yet, but I
will in just a moment.
So at this point, we're armed
with enough knowledge to maybe
look at the Timeline and reverse
engineer, OK, a layout
occurred here.
I don't want one.
What other strategy could
I have used for
that particular effect?
And we can try to remove
layouts, eliminate style
recalculations, that
sort of thing.
So I apologize because I'm going
to be hiding behind my
computer a bit, but I have a
short demo app that I'm going
to show various snaps of
the Timeline from.
So first of all, the effect that
we're going for here is
going to be this little guy
sliding in and out, and that's
just a hover change.
So when I hover in, it
slides in and out.
And I'm going to show you what
the Timeline looks like for
various different ways we can
implement the same effect.
This first one is implemented
with margin.
We can see that we positioned
this element offscreen with a
margin left, and then
we bring it back in
whenever a hover occurs.
So if we go ahead and fire up
our Timeline and we take a
recording, we'll see lots of
exciting things happening.
And I'm going to go ahead and
zoom in here and just analyze
what the browser's had to do.
So we see that there are
a number of style
recalculations.
It is unfortunate that there
are several instead of just
one, but that happens
sometimes.
Chrome in particular is getting
better and better at
combining these things, but we
see that we've got a bunch of
style recalcs, and then we
have a layout here, which
makes sense.
Margin is a layout-related
property.
So even though it didn't push
anything else out of the way,
the rendering tree and the
dimensions of this element
actually had to be updated.
As we scroll down, we continue
to see that there are a series
of recalculate style and layout,
one after the other.
So the way that I have
implemented this is with a CSS
transition, and so the browser
is basically, on my behalf,
going through and saying, well,
the margin left was
negative 215.
Now it's negative 214,
and on, and so forth.
So we'll continue to see a
number of style recalculations
as we go, and we'll also start
to see some paints.
Now I scrolled a bit so my
rectangles will be in the
wrong place, but we can see
that there are little
rectangles that start peeking
in, demonstrating where a flag
comes in and out.
Now, as a hat tip and also a bit
of a frustration for me,
when I started working on this
talk a month ago, those
rectangles were huge and I got a
really big win when I showed
you the next version.
It got faster, and so the impact
is less severe, but we
can still see as we go through
that the browser's having to
do a number of steps before
it can do a single paint.
Sometimes a paint doesn't
even fit in.
We'll get a recalc, a layout,
and then another recalc
without even getting a paint.
So this sort of thing is going
to cause a lower frame rate
for the user.
So we scroll all the way to the
end, and at some point,
everything finished and it
painted the entire little logo
all the way on screen.
And it's not too bad.
This happens to be an incredibly
lightweight page.
If we had a lot more elements
on the page, though, we'd
start getting some jerkiness
that the user
can actually see.
And so we've got a number of
steps that we want to go
through, and we get the biggest
wins at the beginning
of the rendering cycle.
So in particular, can we
eliminate recalcs and can we
eliminate layouts?
So those are the things
that we're going to
try to focus on.
So prior to CSS3, I would have
said to myself, you know,
margin can cause other things on
the page to move around, so
maybe I'll try to absolutely
position this flag and slide
it in and out, because then, I'm
guaranteed it's not going
to affect all those siblings
that are in the flow.
So I'll go ahead and click
Position, and my
CSS is going to change.
This is going to be absolutely
positioned, and I'm going to
use the left property instead
to do the animation.
And I'll weasel it on screen
a little bit, take a new
recording, and zoom in and see
if things got any better.
So I still see a number of
recalculations, and I still
see layouts.
Now, these layouts are going to
be a bit quicker than the
layouts we saw with margin,
but they're still there
because when we looked at the
layout slide, left is still a
property that has to do some
sort of layout calculation.
Now, it's cheaper because it
doesn't affect anything else
on the page, but it's still
going to cost us.
So as we're going down, we still
see that we've got these
recalculations and layouts
interspersed
with all of our painting.
And this is just not going to be
good enough, mostly because
we can do better.
So that wasn't as big a win as
maybe we would have hoped.
However, if we think back to
what I said about layers, it
might occur to us to try a
transformation instead.
Transforms have no
effect on layout.
It's a paint only concept, so
we might give that a try.
So let's take a look at
the CSS we do here.
We're going to use
a transformation.
We're going to translate
x instead of
moving our left property.
So leave the element in the
flow, but go ahead and
reposition it using
a transform.
So I'll go ahead and take
a recording here.
I can tell already there's a lot
more green in here, which
is exactly what I'm
looking for.
So I still see a number of
recalculations at the beginning.
Remember, hovering can cause our
CSS selectors to change.
That's what actually kicked off
my transition, in fact.
But when I continue looking, I
see that there are a large
number of paints at the
beginning, but then as I go
through, I'm getting just a
bunch of composited layers.
So these are incredibly cheap
and easy for the GPU to do,
and so we're going to see a
much smoother transform,
especially if, like I said, we
had a very heavyweight DOM
page that was hard for
the browser to paint.
However, still at the end, we've
got this large paint
right at the end, and at the
beginning, there are a series
of pains as well.
These sort of perplexed me when
I first tried this out
and I was thinking to myself,
there's nothing up there.
What's happening?
But what the browser is actually
doing is it's saying,
well, you added a layer here
but in order to slide that
around, I had to put everything
else on the page in
a layer as well so that the
GPU can composite them.
So this is that little
CSS tag that I have.
This is the links that
are on there.
This is the flag itself.
And then we had to do one big
paint to the whole page to
actually render those layers.
So for the duration of the
animation, we actually get
fairly smooth effects, but at
the beginning and at the end
we have to do a very
large paint.
And since painting is less
efficient than compositing, we
want to try to get the smallest
rectangles that we can.
So you may have heard that
Transform 3D is supposed to
accelerate things, whatever
that means.
So whenever I'm working on my
own, I just sort of take that
as a given and I say, all
right, let's try that.
See if it makes it faster.
So let's go ahead and
take a recording.
You'll see at this point I've
use Translate 3D instead.
I haven't actually done anything
with the y- or the
z-axis, but I'm going to give
it a shot and just see if it
makes a change.
Guess and check, the web
developer's best friend.
So I'll go ahead and zoom in on
here, and I still see that
I've got a large number
of paints that
occur at the beginning.
So I'm thinking to myself that
this is not good enough.
What I want to do is I want to
avoid these initial paints, so
I need to actually take the
things that are present here
and I need to put them in
layers the whole time.
The problem here is that
something is getting popped
out into a layer, it's causing
all this extra
work to have to happen.
So instead, if in the resting
state I put them in layers all
along, I can avoid this.
So I'm going to go and do this
on the fly, hoping not to make
typos in front of all of you.
But I'm going to go ahead and
say that everything will be in
a Translate 3D in its
resting state.
I already have one for the
resting state of the bar, but
I don't have anything for this
list that I've got right here,
so I might try a Transform 3D
and say, don't go anywhere.
Just sit there.
And then I might do the same
thing with this code block
right here.
So my hypothesis is things are
in layers right now, so as
soon as I made that change, we
had to paint each of those
individually to pop them
out into layers.
But now, it shouldn't cause a
hitch at the beginning or the
end of my animation.
They're already in layers.
We don't have to do that work.
So let's give that a shot,
see how accurate it is.
I do see one here.
I apparently missed somebody
somewhere on the page.
But my giant paints that
I had before--
apologies--
no paints, right?
So I completely eliminated
paint as
associated with this layer.
Now obviously, when I introduce
the layer, that
caused a paint, but now I've
taken it out of the places
where I care about smoothness,
which is the
duration of my animation.
So that was the demo, so let's
head back and get a high level
view of the kinds of
things that we want
to try to do here.
So the first and foremost is
we have to get rid of any
JavaScript interruptions
that we have.
If an animation or scrolling is
occurring, we want to make
sure that we're not getting
random JavaScript callbacks,
we're not doing expensive
JavaScript in the middle of
our animation.
Sometimes, maybe you're
implementing something like a
sticky header, you can't avoid
it, but you want to keep it as
lightweight as possible because
any time that we're
spending on our JavaScript
is taking
away time from painting.
So that's the first one.
The next one is we want
to get rid of as
many layouts as possible.
Now, we can't always avoid
a layout occurring.
In fact, not only writing to the
DOM causes a layout, but
sometimes reading from the DOM
causes a layout as well.
So the browser will try to batch
up a series of writes to
the DOM, and if we've
interleaved a bunch of reads
in there, it has to validate the
whole thing before it can
give you an accurate answer.
So for example, if you are
measuring the width of
something and then you write
to the height of something
else and then you get the
offset top of something,
that's going to cause a lot more
layouts instead of the
browser being able to
batch them all up.
So even if we can't fully
eliminate them, we want to get
as few layouts as possible.
And then moving on from there,
we went to minimize our paint
rectangles.
We can't always avoid having
these rectangles, but we want
to get them as small
as possible.
So small in number, small
in size on our paints.
And then if we can, we want to
try to eliminate painting
altogether.
Now again, this whole layer
concept is not anywhere in any
sort of standardized
specification.
It's just one of those things
that we have to do if we want
a great experience for
our users these days.
I will say that a question I
often get is, well, why don't
we just put everything into a
layer and then we don't have
to worry about it?
It does take up some amount of
vRAM, and if you put every
element in the page on a layer,
at that point, there's
so much memory being taken up
and so much work to combine
them all together that you get
very diminishing returns,
especially on a very low power
device like a phone.
And so we have to be a little
bit thoughtful.
We have to choose our layers,
carve up our page in a way
that will actually support
whatever particular effect
we're trying to get.
So these are our takeaways
from this session.
And if we're trying to improve
our rendering time, we want to
start at the top and
go to the bottom.
We'll get the biggest win by
getting rid of our JavaScript
and so on down the page.
There are some links on here,
and I will also have a link to
this slide show, but
there are a ton of
great resources available.
The Chrome Team has been
wonderful about posting things
to the HTML5 Rocks website,
so I definitely highly
recommend that one.
And there are some links on here
that I've found useful.
The last one explains all kinds
of things about the
threading architecture for the
Chrome renderer, so settle in
on that one, but it's definitely
a great read.
And with that, we're going to
go ahead and take questions.
This link is to the slideshow,
so if you'd like to revisit
and click on those links, this
is where you can go.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CHELSEA DERRICK: And if there
are any questions, there are a
couple microphones.
There's one here
in the middle.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Not sure if this is the most
appropriate forum for this
question, but I've always
wondered why every value of
position triggers a layout when
most of them don't really
affect layout that much.
Like position absolute elements
don't affect layout
at all, they're taken
out of the flow.
Position relative elements,
they seem to behave quite
similarly to an element that
has been translated using
transforms.
And of course, fixed elements
are in their own world.
So why do these trigger
a layout?
CHELSEA DERRICK: Yes.
That's a great question, and
definitely one of the places
that browsers have
a long way to go.
We shouldn't have to
think about this.
If I don't have any children and
I'm just a square on the
page and you move my left edge,
it shouldn't affect
anything else.
Why are you wasting the time?
It's sort of a result of the
fact that left can sometimes
have an effect, and it's better
to waste a little time
and make sure you're 100%
accurate rather than to try to
prematurely optimize.
Now, I say the web
is pretty old.
It's not premature anymore.
It's definitely an area for
active development, but it's
hard to do it correctly.
So those are sort of tagged as
layout-related properties, and
so the layouts that they trigger
are shorter than other
layouts, but they
still happen,
AUDIENCE: Got it.
Thank you.
CHELSEA DERRICK: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm wondering, how does SVG play
a role, if you know, in
all this stuff?
CHELSEA DERRICK: Yeah, that's
a great question.
I myself don't have a ton
of experience with SVG.
Right now, SVG, Canvas,
HTML, these are all
very divorced concepts.
They don't share a common layer
underneath anything.
There's a lot of work being
done right now.
Actually, there's a Chrome team
in Google who's working
on a spec for animations that
will have a common layer
underneath all of these
things, but
we're not there yet.
So they're all completely
separate code
branches at the moment.
So things that are going to
work on HTML and CSS don't
necessarily work on
SVG or Canvas.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
CHELSEA DERRICK: All right.
We'll see if anyone happened to
be live streaming and asked
me questions.
Sweet.
I was kind of worried
that it was going to
be unmoderated content.
Are there any other questions?
All right.
Thank you so much
for attending.
[APPLAUSE]